while he says he's no fan of the
commander-in-chief former campaign aide
Sam Nunn Berg said President Trump is
correct
the Special Counsel investigation is a
witch-hunt during a freewheeling phone
interview nunberg said he's refusing to
testify this week before the grand jury
subpoenas absolutely ridiculous
why should I hand them over every email
I've had with Steve been into Roger
stone since November of 2015 that's why
the special counsel has got something on
the president he may have done something
during the election the White House
press secretary dismissed the comments
look I'm not gonna weigh in to somebody
that doesn't work at the White House I
can tell you from our perspective we are
fully cooperating with the office of the
Special Counsel as the latest special
counsel drama unfolded Fox News has
confirmed Robert Mullins investigators
began exploring the Trump campaigns
connections to the United Arab Emirates
and possible business dealings as early
as November last year this is more
Republican lawmakers called for a second
special counsel to investigate alleged
government surveillance abuse during the
2016 election we cannot have the
Department of Justice and we cannot have
the FBI investigate themselves they're
not going to put handcuffs on themselves
they're not going to impanel a grand
jury to investigate themselves with the
issue before Justice Department
Inspector General Michael Horowitz the
Republican chairman of the House
Government Oversight Committee said two
dozen witnesses are already out of reach
I am reluctant to call for special
counsel but I think it may be
unavoidable in this fact pack in a
separate development two sources tell
Fox News that during the 2016 campaign
FBI agent Peter struck was advised about
an irregularity in the Clinton servers
metadata suggesting a possible breach by
a hostile actor but according to the
sources there was no significant follow
up the sources said agents truck also
resisted a formal damage assessment
after classified information beyond top
secret pass through Clinton's personal
server the FBI had no comment and a
spokeswoman for the Inspector General
did not immediately respond Fox News
understands the Inspector General is
aware of the allegations Channel it's
gonna be interesting to see how this
plays out when somebody gets that fast
and loose with all of the details of
what's happening on the inside
Catherine thank you you're welcome